TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is the Developer Show.
I'm standing here
with Susan Koger
who is the co-founder and chief
creative officer of ModCloth.
Susan, welcome.
SUSAN KOGER: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How are you?
SUSAN KOGER: I am wonderful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Me, too.
So we're going to talk about
entrepreneurship and maybe
some advice that you have
for startup founders that
happen to be watching.
But first, and I know you've
told this story like a billion
times, I'd like to talk to you
about the origins of ModCloth.
Is that OK?
SUSAN KOGER: Yeah, of course.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So here's my very
specific question.
You're sitting there in 2002
with Eric, your then boyfriend,
now husband and co-founder.
And you're thinking
to yourselves, wow,
Susan's really
good at antiquing.
Maybe we should spend
all of our free time
making this into a business.
Like how do you cross
from one idea to another.
How did that happen?
SUSAN KOGER: Yeah, I love it.
I built ModCloth while
I was an undergraduate
at Carnegie Mellon.
Just for me and my
style of leadership,
and what I know about myself,
I lead very instinctually.
And I think we did a lot of
things, just me and my husband
being in the business.
Almost like having a beginner
brain kind of approach
to things.
So you do have
to-- so I think it
was very instinctual at first.
You do have to
codify those things
and actually step back
and think about them,
and think about what's working.
These are the things that
we've kind of just done.
What's working from this list?
What can actually
scale and what doesn't?
What needs to go away?
What new things
need to be added in?
For me it was--
starting ModCloth,
like deciding to work on it
full time once I graduated
from CMU, because I did it part
time while I was at school.
I was at the stage where I
was like, man, if I can just
do this and I can
support myself and maybe
hire a few people to do the
stuff that I don't enjoy
doing so much, like packing
boxes is really fun,
but you don't necessarily
want to spend four hours a day
doing it, which is kind
of what I was doing
when I hired my first employee.
Yeah, I was like,
man, if I can just
support myself, and
create this job,
and let's see where it goes.
And it's just continued
to go and grow.
And yeah, I feel really
fortunate to be able to do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So here's a question
based on what
you were saying about having
this job for 14 years.
I can't imagine
it's the same job.
And I have some data
to back that up.
In 2012, 50% growth to
$100 million in sales.
And in 2015, $150
million in sales.
There's no way that
you can get that growth
and still be doing the
same thing every day.
But I'm curious what the
rate of innovation is?
How often does your job change?
And how often do you have
to find new strategies
to grow even bigger, or
to deal with that growth?
SUSAN KOGER: Yeah.
It's a really
interesting question.
And I think-- I mean,
there's been so many phases.
And I used to feel like
my job was changing
almost every quarter,
because honestly, it
is just like we were
growing so quickly.
I want to say in
2010 we hired-- we
had 100 people at the
beginning of the year,
and we hired 150 that year.
So we went from like
100 to like, I think,
225-ish by the time
the year was out.
But it's so different.
And there's no way that you
can hit the level of scale
that we've gotten to, or hit
any scale at all, without being
able to let other people
in and empower them
to do the things that
they do really well.
So part of the process
for me has been
learning how to be a leader.
As much as we've gone from
nothing to where we're
at today, with 350 full time
people across three locations,
the sales numbers
that you referenced,
we're still a small fish
in the big fashion sea.
Like it's a huge industry.
And one that is
ripe for innovation.
And we're doing
things differently
and in a very cool way, I think.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So clearly you've been
at this a long time.
And you've used a
number of different ways
to really help keep the
spirit of the company alive.
Let me just kind of tag a few
of them that I think I heard.
One is that you had to
be really innovative
and you approached it
with this beginner's mind.
That's such a cool idea.
It's like, what's the
company we want to work at?
And you put that into
ModCloth from the beginning.
I think other big
thing that I heard
is that you built
that into the culture
so that throughout, it wasn't
just like a list of rules,
but something people carried
with them as part of ModCloth.
Does that sound right?
SUSAN KOGER: Yeah, definitely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
OK.
I have one more
question for you.
And this is an advice question.
There's somebody out there who
was where you were in 2002.
They have a passion
for something
that they think they can make
into a successful startup.
Where do they start?
SUSAN KOGER: I think the
first thing that I would say
would be to ask for help.
And do it all the time.
And be very concise
and know what you're
looking for at all times.
Right?
You know, if you're doing
something for the first time,
if you get better your taste
is going to get better.
And you're going to look back
on that stuff that you did early
and you're going
to cringe at it.
I look back at the first logo
that I designed for ModCloth,
at our first website, at
our first photo shoots.
And I'm just like, oh, my god.
It looks so bad to me now.
And I didn't think that
when we launched it.
Obviously, like I
cared deeply about it.
It was the best I could do.
So I think that sometimes we
get scared to just put something
out there, because it's scary.
It's vulnerable.
You're putting
something out there.
People might like it.
They might not.
It's like, oh my god.
But here's the thing.
If you're going to succeed,
you're going to get better.
So you've got to
start somewhere.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So don't be afraid
to ask for help.
And you've just got
to get out there.
SUSAN KOGER: Yep.
You've got to get out
there and put something out
into the world.
And you know what, it's
probably going to suck.
And that's OK.
Or it'll be great,
and then you'll
look back at it
five years from now
and you'll say, wow,
that kind of sucked.
And then you'll look back
at it and you'll be like,
oh, this is actually
kind of cute and retro.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Susan, thanks
so much for joining me today.
SUSAN KOGER: Yeah,
thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For more
information about ModCloth--
and maybe we can put some
of your favorite blogs
and blog posts in
the notes as well.
SUSAN KOGER: Amazing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Check
out the show notes below.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]